a la cabeza de la vacunación y en
américa latina chile logró vacunar 5
millones de personas contra el coi 19 en
41 días dos semanas antes de la fecha
prevista por el gobierno para inocular
su población el presidente sebastián
piñera reconoció el logro como el
resultado de un trabajo conjunto tenemos
más de 5 millones de chilenas y chilenos
vacunados local ha sido sin duda un
trabajo
y difícil y que ha significado la
contribución de cientos de miles de
personas chile anunció su campaña de
vacunación el pasado 3 de febrero y
ahora a comienzos de esta semana el
ministerio de salud anunció que ya se
había vacunado al 85% de la población
mayor de 60 años el siguiente objetivo
del gobierno es comenzar a inocular el
próximo 24 de marzo a la población entre
50 y 59 años de edad para esto el
ministro de relaciones exteriores
rodrigo yáñez dijo que continuará los
diálogos con laboratorios
internacionales hemos seguido
conversaciones con otros laboratorios
pensando en enfrentar lo que va a ser el
segundo trimestre
que va a ser muy importante para
terminar este ciclo de vacunación de la
población objetivo que es el 80 por
ciento de la población y 15 por 15
millones de personas si bien esta es una
noticia alentadora el país suramericano
debe esperar para cantar victoria con un
repunte de 5.000 nuevos casos de
contagio al día y el 65% de ocupación de
las 3.200 camas de uso disponibles es
pronto para que los 5 millones de
vacunas influyan en los marcadores
epidemiológicos del territorio